[Música]
y bienvenidos a esta emisión especial de
noticias dedicada al continente africano
mi nombre es andrés meza muñoz y estos
son nuestros titulares de los siete
golpes de estado que tuvieron lugar en
el mundo durante 2021 6 se presentaron
en áfrica mali níger chad guinea 2 en
sudán aunque uno de ellos fracasó en
esta misión especial analizaremos sus
orígenes y efectos un año después de que
se aplicará la primera vacuna contra el
cob y 19 más de la mitad de la población
ha sido vacunada pero la situación en
áfrica es otra sólo el 11% de los
habitantes del continente han recibido
el fármaco mientras la variante omicron
detectada en sudáfrica ha provocado que
varios países se vean aislados
2021 fue un año grandioso para la
literatura africana tres de los premios
más prestigiosos pero entregados a
escritores de este continente entre
ellos el nobel les contamos de quiénes
se trata
el 2021 hubo siete golpes e intentos de
golpe de estado en el mundo seis de
ellos tuvieron lugar en áfrica mientras
que sólo uno se produjo fuera del
continente en mi amar mali níger chad
guinea y sudan a sucesivamente visto sus
gobiernos o gobiernos de transición
derrocados por los militares con o sin
el apoyo de la población veamos un
informe sobre las diferentes razonadas
militares que el continente ha
experimentado este año
está en peligro la democracia en áfrica
en 2021 una serie de levantamientos
militares contra regímenes frágiles
azotaron el continente los golpes se
produjeron principalmente en la región
del sur sahara una zona históricamente
más afectada por los derrocamientos de
este tipo en mali el ex presidente
ibrahim abu bakr keita fue detenido por
los militares en agosto de 2000 20 meses
después se creó un gobierno de
transición con el objetivo de devolver
el poder a los civiles
pero en mayo de 2021 los militares lo
derrocaron culpándolo de dejar fuera a
varios de ellos tras este golpe que
desencadenó una crisis diplomática con
francia el coronel así militar se
convirtió en presidente de la transición
quisiera asegurar a las organizaciones
subregionales y regionales y a la
comunidad internacional en general que
malí cumplirá todos sus compromisos para
los intereses de la nación
pocos días después de la muerte de su
padre triste vi al frente del país desde
1990 su hijo mahamat idriss deby es
impuesto por los militares en chile al
presidente alpha condé fue destituido en
septiembre por los uniformados tras su
polémica reelección
el coronel mamá ya prometió devolver el
poder a los civiles tras un periodo de
transición cuya duración sigue siendo
incierto
quiero reiterar aquí mi compromiso de
que ni yo ni ningún miembro del comité
nacional de las agrupaciones para el
desarrollo y los órganos de la
transición seremos candidatos en las
próximas elecciones no se va a cantidad
o selección ha venido en sudán tras un
golpe fallido en septiembre se produjo
otro en octubre en el que el general
abdelfatah albor hunt disolvió la rama
civil del gobierno de transición y tomó
el poder antes de restituir el primer
ministro jan doc desde las
independencias se calcula que más de 200
golpes militares se produjeron en áfrica
y para entender las razones detrás de
los golpes de estado en el continente
africano previamente hablamos louis
manipulada como periodista y presidente
del club la información de áfrica
a él le consultamos que ha provocado
tantos golpes en la zona en un solo año
y cuáles son sus características comunes
yo
son
legión creo que los golpes de estado se
deben a que la gente tiene la impresión
de que ya no puede obtener la
alternancia a la que aspira a través de
las elecciones y entonces si no
consiguen la alternancia por la vía
electoral optan por el medio que les
parece el más adecuado el que ya conocen
que es el golpe de estado y esto es lo
que puede explicar por ejemplo que con
el hecho de que hayamos limitado el
mandato y que hayamos intentado que haya
al menos dos vueltas electorales en los
países los dirigentes en el poder
siempre están tratando de encontrar una
manera de evitar estos obstáculos que se
han puesto para evitar que entren en una
cierta forma de autoritarismo
y la gente se ve obligada a esquivar
esta dificultad como mejor puede como lo
vimos en guinea un golpe de estado que
es bien recibido por la población es
algo bastante singular
en mali ocurrió lo mismo y lo terrible
es que además la posición de la cedeao
la comunidad de desarrollo económico de
áfrica occidental es inaudible en este
asunto porque se estima que se trata de
un club de jefes de estado que se apoyan
mutuamente y que no se preocupan por las
aspiraciones del pueblo y entonces la
cedeao del pueblo no existe es la cedeao
de los jefes de estado y es ante estas
exasperación es en mi opinión que el
pueblo ha optado por confiar en quienes
pueden tener más fuerza que los
políticos para ayudarles a conseguir sus
objetivos
es decir en los militares y por tanto en
el golpe de estado que le políticia
poles de idea de los objetivos del día
de militar y don de calidad
también le consultamos si la toma de
poder por parte del ejército coincide
con la falta de instituciones de
contrapoder
fusión del club existe incluso cuando
las instituciones de contrapoder existen
no son lo suficientemente fuertes como
para evitar que los que están en el
poder hagan lo que quieran y ahí es
cuando entra el ejército como regulador
pero tampoco creo que sea la solución
correcta lo que se necesita hoy en día
es un juego democrático en el que no
haya hombres providenciales porque si
hay un hombre providencial que aparece
como una especie de rey monarquía
monarquía divina aspiración divina la
gente espera mucho pero sólo son hombres
pueden cometer errores por eso es hoy
necesario crear verdaderas instituciones
de contrapoder no sólo sociedades
civiles no instituciones en las que el
presidente tenga la última palabra para
nombrar o destituir a las personas sino
verdaderas instituciones que garanticen
que cada uno de los bandos en pugna
tenga miedo de la policía y por tanto se
comporten bien en interés de la
democracia y del grupo también hablamos
con wii manglar como yo sobre los
ejemplos de países africanos con una
democracia fuerte
afortunadamente hay buenos ejemplos
puede que no sean muchos pero los hay
tomando la zona donde se produjeron
estos golpes de estado un país africano
francófono perteneciente a la cedeao
como senegal por ejemplo es un buen
ejemplo su democracia se mantuvo igual a
sí misma durante todos los años
incluso cuando abdulá igual al final de
su segundo mandato quiso presentarse a
un tercero reformó la constitución hizo
todo lo que pudo para mantenerse en el
poder pero los votantes no confiaron en
él y por eso lo echaron al final de esas
elecciones no pudo hacer un tercer
mandato otro ejemplo muy bueno es el de
cabo verde y si nos salimos de todos
estos ejemplos miremos a ghana donde
hubo un golpe de estado pero después el
país se volvió tan virtuoso que hoy se
convierte en un ejemplo de democracia
para la mayoría de la gente podríamos
citar otros ejemplos pero creo que en
esta zona de la cedeao ya hay algunos
ejemplos en los que podemos basarnos
para decir que es posible encontrar
países africanos en los que se respete
el juego democrático
y en los que los actores entiendan que
la alternancia no es una opción que es
una parte inherente al juego democrático
y al ejercicio del poder democrático
cambiamos de tema a otra importante
noticia en áfrica es la situación por
kobe 19 allí el número de fallecidos por
la pandemia ha superado los 200.000
aunque áfrica ha evitado los escenarios
catastróficos que se temían al inicio de
la pandemia el problema de las vacunas
persiste de acuerdo con el portal a word
sing deira al momento de grabar este
programa sólo el 11% de la población
africana estaba vacunada y el 8% contaba
con la pauta completa en comparación con
el 70 por ciento de las regiones como
américa del sur o américa del norte la
desigualdad de la inmunización entre
naciones ricas y la de bajos ingresos es
tal que los países del g20 por ejemplo
han recibido 15 veces más dosis de
vacunas por cada habitante que los
países del áfrica subsahariana según la
empresa de análisis científico el fin ir
y este desequilibrio la inmunización se
produce además en un momento en el que
la región también tiene dificultades
para enfrentar la creciente demanda de
productos desde vacunación como las
jeringas muchos expertos sostienen por
otra parte que esta desigualdad y la
consiguiente lentitud de la vacunación
en el continente podría estar detrás de
la aparición de variantes como omicron
que ha aparecido recientemente en
sudáfrica y que sea o que ha causado
restricciones contra este y otros países
de esa región previamente discutimos
este tema con martín gómez médico en
sudáfrica
pienso también que se siente un muy mal
precedente para pares de países que
dependen mucho del mismo o con economías
en desarrollo porque podría desmotivar a
los países a reportar oportunamente
cambios o hallazgos que hayan visto en
la estructura o en nuevas variantes del
virus sea con con el coronavirus o sea
con cualquier otro tipo de enfermedad y
sudáfrica en teoría
nuevamente fue castigado probation
transparente es muy sencillo con y sin
vacunas la historia natural de él es de
agentes como los virus es mutar contar
para lograr sobrevivir
los medios incluso organizaciones
internacionales parecen escandalizadas
cuando encuentran una adaptación virus
ciudad área y font y todos los otros
organismos han estado montando por miles
y miles de años y es nada nuevo y lo que
yo sí pienso ha sido parte de
distribución de las vacunas
al principio tuvimos mucha escasez de
vacunas en sudáfrica más que con la
región donde yo estoy
ahorita lo que estamos viendo es hay
vacunas pero hemos encontrado el
obstáculo de la parte de vista de
educación la gente ya no usted quiere
vacunar es imposible determinar si la
vacunación o falta de ella
es la causal de micro pero sí es una
parte
importante recalcar que nosotros toda
áfrica ha sido en gran parte del mundo
sigue habiendo ese
escepticismo
sobre
respecto a las vacunas pero no todo han
sido malas noticias en 2021 ha sido un
gran año para la novela africana varios
escritores han sido premiados más allá
de las fronteras de sus países el
goncourt prestigioso premio literario de
francia fue concedido al senegalés
mohammed en vulgar azar es el primer
autor africano galardonado con este
premio y uno de los más jóvenes en
octubre otro escritor de senegal
boubacar boris diop fue nombrado ganador
del premio internacional de literatura
neustadt
otro premio sin duda el más prestigioso
fue el galardón el nobel de literatura-
2021 que se concedió al novelista tan
sano abdul razak journal con estas
imágenes despedimos este especial
informativo áfrica siete días aquí en
france 24 continúen con más información
[Música]